a person close to the couple says that
they are getting funky in the bedroom
and have included a lot of bondage and
sex toys and my husband and I were so
flattered hi I'm Kristen Bell and this
is first and last for Tyler
the first personal challenge that I
undertook was wow it's silly but when I
was little I was not very aware of my
surroundings the fridge where I grew up
was at the bottom and the freezers at
the top and every time someone opened
that door I walked into it for years I
had a permanent bruise on my forehead my
first personal challenge was being
self-aware enough to know when that door
was gonna open and how to get out of the
way the last personal challenge that I
undertook was figuring out how to apply
a calmer sense of self when I am in the
middle of a press tour the first fake
news story printed about me I feel like
I should remember this fondly I wish i
oh well I'll tell you a recent one a
person close to the couple says that
they are getting funky in the bedroom
and have included a lot of bondage and
sex toys and my husband and I were so
flattered
the last fake news story printed about
me I know this one too recently I
discovered rose' but my husband is sober
and that really threw the tabloids for a
loop
and they thought I'm gonna bring him
down little do they know that he works
just fine on his sobriety even if mommy
has an afternoon glass of Rose a my
first starstruck moment was when I saw
Ty Pennington who used to host Extreme
Home Makeover at the People's Choice
Awards
and I about lost my marbles my last
starstruck moment is when I saw
Annabelle Wallis at an event in Los
Angeles and I'm a huge peaky blinders
fan because we definitely dressed as the
characters for my friend's birthday
party and I think I told her that and
then also showed her the picture but you
know when you're like I want to show you
the picture hold on I'm gonna get it
it's almost here did have it and then
it's just like an hour of that so the
first gift I got someone oh I don't know
but I love giving gifts it's my very
favorite thing in the world
here's a great gift to give someone who
has everything you find one of their
favorite books I've done this twice the
first time I did it was for my husband
his name is Dax and I got a first
edition copy of the adventurers and then
I sent it around to his family for a
couple months and they all signed it
they graffiti'd the book they put
pictures of him
told him why he loved it those are the
best presents I've ever gotten anyone
the first time I noticed everyday sexism
Wow
to be honest I don't think I noticed
everyday sexism until people really
started talking about it which is why I
am grateful for public discourse and
conversations because we need to talk
about things in order to recognize them
the last time I noticed everyday sexism
was every day since we started talking
about it the first time I was recognized
on the street I don't remember the first
time I was recognized but I do remember
since I've been recognized sometimes I
hide a little bit more not because I
don't appreciate it but just because I
don't know just want to be inside my
head cuz I'm sometimes an introvert so
sometimes I hide the last time I was
recognized on the street was last night
at the frozen premiere I'm pretty sure
everybody knew who I was there were so
many kids there it was really fun
I'm Kristen Bell and this was first and
last for Tyler I can't that's the thing
is I can't because I have to clean up
restaurants when I leave because I'm a
mom
you